my name is Pat welcome back to the
condemned this pretty fun right died and
I said it's gotta be the kind of
tryharding trying out sit on my crime
it's got a shotgun oh that's right I'm
getting that shotgun are you doing
humping each other
[ __ ] that's table flip if we can nuke me
not fair I think we did that bird stop
breakdancing seriously but cannot be
breakdancing I don't know how many times
I tell them they're like but beer
that's my baby Oh what are you doing
that don't you dare you yeah what are
you doing to the shell I did this shelf
ever do to you you look at another one
oh that guy just likes opening doors
come here come at me bro come at me bro
thank you bro like in your teeth right
between that [ __ ] lab down the side all
right here comes the tricky part
gotta wait for my tailor well here comes
the final that finale
oh that's right oh that's right oh
that's right move aside you little [ __ ]
holy [ __ ]
thank you bro that's right you like that
now deck shot that's how I roll but
someone else
holy [ __ ] you're a big shot that guy's
MLG how do I punch people that's how we
open the cabinet you shoot the [ __ ] out
of that [ __ ] all right let's keep going
shall we stop shoddy
hiya dad
yeah sorry I have a guy
I don't know women like damn is there
aren't any women in here oh look at this
how do I crouch that's the problem
that's how you kick series of women
after filthy look at this [ __ ]
I think I needed her let's go to the
men's room
that's pretty I felt it suits me that
dead bird in the toilet I don't see why
I shouldn't collect it ha this game
makes total sense at a lot of times but
what is this mosquito
alright it's got to be a trace here
there we go the Trey's ends here and
continues I heard someone what are you
doing down there
what yeah keeps going here they trick me
they tricked you did you want it to high
fire me
wow I hit my life vodka
[Music]
I get enough that's my gift
whoa who closed that door don't anyone
be in here I get in now my gift is that
I can like see in the future but I can
also move stuff without with the force I
am cool
I move that bring it [ __ ] it says you
stopped for that freakin flashback thing
it's a big bear [ __ ] my belt Peter I
know
Jesus Christ we talked before oh wait
wait hey hey well that was it alrights
means oh this is his office
I come I guess we got to look for
evidence and stuff oh cool
let's take make sense right
all right got one like to call the girl
and be like girl just actress yeah I
know picture of my dick that's right a
lot of these days
I'm still running frequency analysis
Electra 10 what could that possibly mean
excuse me pictures I need to go in here
picture it's don't be really good I
can't go there all right that's fair
enough
beep eh I guess we should pick up shotty
sorry if you say I love you
it's a KPD all right well
I guess I gotta record this Oh bang a
prat all right how much I assume oh
there we go
why did these gadgets anyway I can't
really make sensor yeah you're welcome
okay
do it girl whoa someone in there I can
introduce you to shot if you want Wow
whoa yeah what are you doing seriously
do you want to die
really whoa you survived that hey don't
sweat and shot his present whoa hey
teleport anybody what are you high
stop fighting me oh you taste you whoa
I need to kill you [ __ ] is going on here
and tell apartment [ __ ]
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah never admit it I lost my
sense of talking shot to help me
wow that's right shot it back hell yeah
we must make haste come on [ __ ] go over
it yeah yeah yeah sure take your time
buddy all right I know you're in here
[ __ ] all right here we go
give me that [ __ ] back back power we
were all right how about we're not going
up it's like a labyrinth
I love labyrinth I hit mr. Schad why are
you so awkward fine
guess I'll keep going then another one
of those dead first hey what are you
doing that I totally taste his ass what
the [ __ ] I got them what is that ah
[ __ ] taser like last thing you how
long whoa I hear someone come here
you're coming from that you are a power
that's right
don't come to me you see you last year
prepare a grab smile people what are you
doing number three makes us sense he
keeps jumping up that's right
taste your head bro that's up till now
I'm very good probably right be back
wait wait wait wait why do you keep
changing sex they done that are you
transvestite pepper
whoa what well let's do it
dead birds yeah that's guessing game
yeah
that birds matter yeah oh look at this
looks pretty pointless you know I can
totally hear you right
pass through doors to complete chapter
all right
nailed it that's how I roll let's
continue right away
according to dr. Feldman Broten that's a
bass name right there I know right we're
in the sewer now suspect last seen
passing through it's a it's a conduit
looks pretty badass all right I think
I'll go with the prepare for this for
now ah I were in the subway now I want
okay over there I want to help you whoa
what are they doing having a dance off
without me hey don't you dad have a dad
oh don't you run away from me not done
dancing yet are you okay there sorry are
you okay hey [ __ ] it I guess I got to
keep them b-pack how did you do to you I
don't know Sharon complained
what dad's back [ __ ] his asthma's made
be made by this steel he must be Segway
guy hey hey goddamn every Titus well I
guess technically if you have an ass of
Steel whoa he's badasses [ __ ] look at
that [ __ ] now whatever all right we got
a fine axe axe knees
well freaking hobos mad hey I want to
borrow your axe that cool that call hey
hey watch where you submit to swing that
thing hey hey don't make me chase you
get a girl whole Bichette trying to look
like Jesus and stuff you're not Jesus
are you gonna run away from what the
[ __ ] are you going
come back here Jesus can't hide from me
that's right I can pace you are yeah I
know it hurts now eat no matter ah
that's my favorite I got to do that one
more after well everyone saves it hobo
you got backup holy [ __ ] how to call cut
okay I got it taste one of them what are
you doing with the door are you going
with that door man not whatever I gotta
fight this one first
ah [ __ ] it man hey watch where that
swing that door I don't stop using
tactics against me swing that daughter
somewhere it's not a door
Bayless door swinging obviously you know
it's among a proper door between that's
right it comes hey cops watch ah ha
hi that [ __ ] hurt I'm just kidding it
didn't where's the revolving know he had
one
come on man how dare you I wait how they
oh look at this
he's so shiny shiny and nice ah [ __ ] me
I need that so step back like why did I
kill all those people
and Jesus sorry I would not inside Jesus
I'm sorry maybe they just people it's
probably
impersonate there here we go hey IRA
oh I got to do it twice alright what's
up everyone I guess I should technically
probably meant that go back and take
care of all the room feels like the best
thing to do in this situation I've been
getting a lot of comments saying that my
choice of weapons are probably not the
best that does not matter
stand aside a is the four side or you
have admissible arms maybe could be but
finding it out there
alright sewers bring your best side
holding this man and Trust homeless man
hey wake up hey man not Carl hi whatever
hey another one how you there you don't
look very good
you don't look very good at all there's
a kick for a good luck I'll be on my way
now
checking fav Punk
cool hi then Jesus oh [ __ ] he really is
Jesus
hey oh there we go well I saved his life
I guess not everybody okay hey hey power
and revolver slash they watch wetson
damage don't you just die oh no no look
at my house you can't see my house
it's pretty [ __ ] it up
oh no no ha ha ha that's right
you gotta hold my headphones how do I
say fall off goddamn I'm screwed aren't
I sorry the hell is he doing
it disappeared come you know I can see
you're right
oh all right
I will actually under breath so like
very ginger I subscribe to cumin road
today and I'll see you next video
[Music]